so broncos can't leave draft weekend
without what chris
i think middle linebacker i think that's
what i look up stand-up middle
linebacker would be the one
area that you know i look at vic fangio
and go
wait he was with the 49ers awesome oh
that's right bowman patrick willis right
yeah bam
okay it was with the bears oh they
drafted roquan smith and had denny
trevathon man awesome boom
he doesn't have that in denver right now
sitting at number nine
i don't expect them to go quarterback
maybe they do
but i would think that nine could be
certainly a position maybe where they
think about middle linebacker the micah
parsons from penn state he could be in
that conversation for them
and make sense certainly a fit but
either way i think it's a position
that needs to be addressed whether
that's in the first round at nine
or somewhere in the second or third uh
they need that guy to
to kind of fill that void for the fangio
scheme you know one of the big mysteries
of the broncos this off season was what
they were going to do with the final
year of von miller's contract they've
picked up the option i still don't think
that's over just because they guaranteed
part of the salary
right doesn't mean he's going to be with
the team this year or beyond he's under
contract for one more year i think edge
rusher needs to be on the radar hear you
for the denver broncos george payton the
gm of the team came over from the
vikings
the vikings with their best when they
had a potent and deep rotation
at pass rusher also running back philip
lindsay
fell out of favor quickly uh they've got
melvin gordon
under a higher value contract and one
thing peyton was able to do with the
vikings and we don't know who was making
these calls and finding these guys but
they
they had dalvin cook and alexander
madison they had mike boone who
who they couldn't keep around and peyton
brings boone in
quickly into denver i i trust peyton's
ability to find running backs
in value positions in the draft and i
think they're going to need a body
that they can that they can have it
cheap amounts
so that maybe they could move on from
melvin gordon after this year no i i
think you're exactly right they got to
think about the future with that
position a little bit yeah they got a
little depth of maybe not like that
go-to got go-to guy to look at for the
future and
yeah phil leblindsey you know we'll see
you know he's the horror story of
running backs in the nfl
he's the horror story that's this is the
guy where it's like
yeah it was some good years early on but
he's 195 running back 195 pound running
back who would run through a brick wall
and now it's like oh gosh he's falling
apart a little bit and that's what
happened last year so we'll see what
they can get out of them this year
yeah i mean when you're that size and
you keep running to a brick wall
eventually it breaks exactly
and i remember when we we had him on
site at the super bowl in
miami i believe and i was just i was
taken aback
and he didn't have that thickness that
you typically see
in a running back who's going to be in
those car crashes as you explain them
all the time you're just not going to
hold up right
if you're not built that way you're only
going to be able to take so many of
those hits before it's
over and we'll see how it goes for
philip lindsay as he moves forward with
his career the chargers
13th overall pick lucky number 13 on
april 13. they got lucky last year with
justin herbert
what do they need this year as brandon
staley takes over as the head coach
i i think the the thing i come back to
more than anything is offensive lineman
and slash a really offensive tackle you
know
they do have the ability there in that
first round pick to go
best lineman available a guy like matt
filer you know he does have that ability
on the chargers so they sign from
pittsburgh to play guard or tackle
but i think ultimately what they need is
that legit franchise left tackle
you know yeah just it's really again
the roster of the chargers is pretty
damn good
they were seven and nine last year and
had some unbelievably dysfunctional
losses
you know when you really look at them
you go wow for a seven and nine
non-playoff team there's a lot to like
and you know derwyn james didn't even
play last year
so i go back i go back to tackle as
being the one i look at
corner is certainly another one mike you
could probably highlight i don't know
anything else jump out to you there with
the chargers
well i i no i'm with you on offensive
line
learn the lesson that the bengals
learned the hard way last year with joe
burrow
don't let justin herbert get in a
situation where he's not available to
play because he's been injured put the
money put the draft picks put the time
put the effort into improving your
offensive line
and let justin herbert do his thing it's
it's that simple and their defense
is good enough if they can just keep all
their guys healthy all right the
las vegas raiders have huge turnover on
the offensive line 60
of their starting offensive line gone
what must they get
this year in the draft chris well i mean
it's front seven front seven
front seven front seven i mean that's
what they need
difference makers in the front seven i
don't give a damn where they come from
preferably though
really probably middle linebacker that's
the one area they need
hey they're gonna be running gus bradley
the seattle scheme defense
you know they're in one of those things
the positions and and i believe they're
at pick 17
right where it's just go pick the best
front seven player
available you know for the for the las
vegas raiders that that's what it comes
down to and whether
i don't know if that's another pass
rusher you know i don't know if there's
going to be a defense a tackle
that you know is in that range it's
probably going to be maybe
maybe the two defensive tackles the kid
from washington and alabama start to
come into favor there right
uh jeremiah owusu coramoa mike
the linebacker from notre dame who i've
got a first-hand look at many times
he would fit that speed fred warner
darius leonard middle linebacker for
that defensive scheme that would make a
lot of sense but
i come back to that front seven uh you
know i don't know
you you with me there you think that's
the spot too yeah that and the offensive
line
i mean when trent brown gabe jackson and
rodney hudson are all gone
you you got your franchise quarterback
wondering what in the hell
am i going to do this year to buy time
to throw passes
mike mack is now entering year three as
the general manager of the team
they had reggie mckenzie there he got
thrown overboard after one season with
john gruden and look it's john gruden's
show
and one of the reasons that mayhawk is
the gm quite frankly is
when gruden's got final say you can't
pluck someone away from another team at
least under the rules that were in place
at the time
you couldn't just go in and say we want
to hire your director of college
scouting
because gruden's still got final say
right so
mayok basically hey look i don't know
how much of the board is mayhawk how
much of its gruden i suspect gruden's
got his fingerprints on
everything they've had five first-round
picks
over the past two years and i know it's
a crap shoot
but it hasn't been great you know
cleveland farrell stands out and i
defended mayoff when he was the fourth
overall
and people were like what the hell
cleland farrell i said hey one of the
reasons that we don't know who cleveland
farrell is
mike mayhawk wasn't here to tell us who
cleveland farrell was in the run-up to
the draft
or he would have been on everyone's
radar screen but farrell's got to turn
into a good player
or it doesn't validate that that belief
that you have in feral
and and you know it was it was they they
sold it as kind of a cultural thing you
know
you don't use a fourth overall pick on a
guy who's going to become a good leader
that's who he's a fifth round pick on
chris
right i mean that really i mean honestly
you know farrell was the 34th pick of
the draft not the fourth pick of the
draft
that was a reach there's no doubt about
it you know yeah
you know the the pressure's on them a
little bit there's no doubt
you know jonathan abrams is it but wait
is the pressure on mayok or is the
pressure on gruden i think the
pressure's on mayok
i think the pressure isn't going to be
on gruden for a while because his
buddy's not going to fire him i
i i agree i don't think there's pressure
on gruden i
i think there is pressure on [ __ ] mayok
because even you know just
social media the public perception you
you listen to the raiders fans and
things like that i i feel like there is
questions about that and specifically
the draft
and i mean you're right you don't know
where that fault really lies there a
little bit
but yeah there's just there's been some
questionable things hey listen jonathan
abrams has good talent but it hasn't
quite worked out yet he's all over the
place on the football field
he's kamikaze he's fun to watch but he
can mess up and do great or whatever
you know they they they reached a little
last year but damon arnett
you know as a top 20 pick that was a guy
i think you know myself a lot of people
just looked at it was like hey he's a
good player
you know you take them in the top 60
picks of the draft i don't know about
the top 20.
so when you do those type of things and
cleveland farrell
you know and henry ruggs as the first
receiver off the board
it wasn't really a special year people
start to whoa let's hone in here wait
what's the issue here what are they
doing
where have they messed up and uh yeah
they got to get some of those guys to
help them out and they got to capitalize
on this year's draft in a big way
and this is an area with john gruden
where you reel in your ego just a little
bit
and you let someone else take the blame
for
for you know pics that your fingerprints
are on but just go ahead and call them
mayhawk picks and then if this year
doesn't work mayhawk's gone and they
find another gm to be the fall guy
eventually for john gruden if it doesn't
work out kansas city chiefs
do we even need to have a discussion
with well i mean we know it was the
number one did we not watch the super
bowl
the number one need is as it is with the
chargers protect the franchise get
offensive linemen yeah i i don't think
there's any doubt about that and
specifically it's tackles they need a
tackle
you know they they they signed joe
tooney that's great
you know they they do have a a kyle long
coming back that could help out you know
uh
tardy deref with how the hell do you say
his last name
loretta rain during tardis he'll be back
so that does help out but i think you
know ultimately what we're talking about
is yes they need to tackle
i don't know if that's gonna be with
pick 31 or at the end of the second
round or whatever but either way
it has to be addressed there's no doubt
about it they don't have enough of them
on the roster and there's just not
enough proven entities at that position
on the roster
i would think that's something that has
to be done yeah it was eric fisher the
first overall pick in 2013 who was
cut after tearing an achilles tendon in
the postseason mr schwartz released
as well and uh we saw what happened see
their super bowl
and without extra help for the tackle
well and that's where like
can we put that graphic back up kristen
i mean here's a perfect example of like
you know oh you know again numbers don't
always tell the story
yeah mahomes was sacked 13 times last
year you'd think oh okay that was a
pretty good year
well i mean first off you look at the
pressures that's way up so that's going
to open your eyes
but also within that i mean mahomes
hid the deficiencies there how many
times during the middle of the year
late middle of the year we'll be going
holy crap was that bad
pass protection yesterday but we just
don't even think anything of it because
mahomes makes a move and a slide and
throws a sidearm
laser 20 yards down the field and we
just go oh yeah i forgot there was
pressure on that play he made that look
so easy and fun
and and gradually over time quite
possibly he
tears ligaments in his the big toe of
his left foot
yeah and when when you're running a mile
during the game and he had ridiculous
numbers in the super bowl he had
ridiculous numbers in the loss to the
raiders
when you're running that much before you
throw the football that's going to add
to the overall wear and tear you put
those cleats on they're tight on your
foot
you step a wrong way you start a problem
and then it just keeps building up and
building up by the end of the season you
may have
turf hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports